l'intensité des combats ne faiblit pas à
soledar et à bark Mount ces deux villes
de l'est de l'Ukraine sont sous la
pression des forces russes mais les
soldats Ukrainiens tiennent comme
l'affirme qui Ève hier volody
mirzuelinski a promis de fournir tout le
nécessaire en terme d'équipement de
munitions aux unités
ukrainiennes qui défendent ces villes et
pour en parler nous retrouvons notre
envoyé spécial à mi-colaïve Mélina Huet
bonjour Mélina c'est Deville les Russes
tentent coûte que coûte les conquérir
elles sont devenues symboliques
absolument polynés vous l'avez dit en
introduction vos ledimère zenenski qui a
rencontré l'état-major hier l'a dit
l'affirmé toutes les armes nécessaires
pour faire tenir ces villes seront
fournies au soldats Ukrainiens c'est une
guerre très symbolique et de faite parce
que depuis la deuxième partie du mois de
mai les Ukrainiens ont décidé qu'il ne
lâcherait pas un seul centimètre carré
de ces terres Horus mais c'est une
grande difficulté c'est une guerre
d'attrition à qui a lieu là-bas grande
difficulté pourquoi parce que la
stratégie russe c'est d'envoyer des
salves d'hommes pour s'écraser et bien
sur les soldats Ukrainiens une première
salve qui est disons-le de la chair à
canon qui vient s'écraser sur les lignes
de défense ukrainienne puis une deuxième
puis une troisième jusqu'à quatre salles
alors ce que les Ukrainiens explique
c'est que il combattent aujourd'hui sur
des cadavres des centaines de cadavres
de russes mais les pertes sont et bien
affirmés sont admises des deux côtés
aussi bien du côté russe qui est assez
rare mais également du côté ukrainien
podoliaque le Conseiller à la Présidence
de zellens et bien l'a dit effectivement
les pertes sont très très nombreuses il
faut dire que il y a là-bas et bien la
milice privée Wagner qui agit qui a
d'ailleurs revendiqué la prise totale de
Solidar juste à côté de barmut il y a
quelques jours ce que les autorités
ukrainiennes démentent mais ce qui est
vrai et c'est que et bien cette bataille
qui continue et qui continue depuis
plusieurs mois devient de plus en plus
difficile pour les autorités
ukrainiennes elle est symbolique vous
l'avez dit mais elle est aussi
stratégique pour la ministre privée
Wagner il s'agit aussi de se saisir de
la plus grande mine de sel d'Europe
Solidar signifie donner le sel il y a
donc aussi une portée stratégique pour
cette ministre privée qui a l'habitude
ne s'emparer de ressources naturelles
que ce soit sur le continent africain ou
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
sur le territoire
ukrainien mais c'est également une voix
un hub stratégique logistique qui
pourrait leur permettre si jamais ils
conquérir les villes de barmouth et de
soledar de pouvoir aller plus plus loin
jusqu'à cramator ce qui éventuellement
et même jusqu'à ce que la viande Mélina
à chaque retrait des troupe russe les
autorités ukrainiennes affirment
découvrir de nouvelles preuves de
torture sur les populations comment
s'effectue ce travail de collecte
viens ici effectue de manière assez
difficile je dois le dire ce qui est
très compliqué pour les autorités
ukrainiennes qui ont commencé le travail
d'investigation sans attendre la fin de
la guerre c'est que cette collecte de
preuves est extrêmement difficile alors
on parle beaucoup de chambres de torture
qui ont été découvertes dans les
endroits récemment libérés qu'il
s'agisse de certains endroits dans le
Dombas ou bien le Blas de rakif qui a
été libéré à la fin de septembre début
octobre ou encore dans le blast de
Helson où nous sommes rendus hier la
ville de Helson notamment qui a été
libérée le 11 novembre dernier nous
sommes rendus dans cette ville hier avec
une brigade mobile du procureur de Kiev
de la procureur de Kev qui est en charge
d'une spécificité les crimes sexuels en
temps de guerre alors nous avons
accompagné une équipe du procureur dans
la ville de Helson à la rencontre de
deux survivants nous ne donnerons pas
leur nom pour des raisons évidentes mais
nous avons assisté à l'entretien d'un de
ces procureurs avec deux victimes la
première un homme un civil qui affirme
avoir été torturé qui a expliqué
longuement comment se laisser passer
selon mais il explique notamment avoir
subi des tortures avec de l'électricité
sur ces parties génitales parce que
quand on pense aux violences sexuelles
en temps de guerre on pense souvent à la
nudité forcée on pense souvent au viol
mais il y a également ceux-ci des
parties génitales qui sont qui sont
torturés avec avec de l'électricité
est-ce que nous expliquait le procureur
c'est que il l'avait déjà vu en 2014
dans le don-basse la volonté pour les
Russes qui certains l'affirment dans des
vidéos même qu'ils filment eux-mêmes
c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas que les
Ukrainiens puissent procréer et donc
cela fait partie de la juridiction de se
procureur de cette procureur en charge
des violences sexuelles nous avons
également rencontré un autre homme qui
lui était entendu en qualité de témoin
et qui expliquait les viols qui avaient
subi ces compagnons d'infortunes dans
une cellule dans laquelle il a été et
bien emprisonné pendant plus de 1 mois
et demi ce qui est difficile avec la
collecte de ses preuves c'est qu'au-delà
des preuves matérielles donc il y a
parfois des vidéos qui sont prises par
les forces russes elles-mêmes et qui
sont ensuite envoyés sur telegram à de
nombreux autres soldats c'est que
lorsqu'il y a des violences physiques et
bien comme c'est le cas pour l'une des
personnes que nous avons rencontrées et
bien c'est difficile parce que c'est
torture ont lieu selon eux à des moments
où les territoires sont encore occupés
par les Russes et dans son cas à lui par
exemple il a filmé ma voix était torturé
en septembre or la ville de Rexel a été
libérée en novembre alors vous le voyez
la collecte de ses preuves va être
compliquée c'est extrêmement important
pour les autorités ukrainiennes parce
qu'ils espèrent à terme pouvoir amener
la Russie devant un tribunal
international